dr. strange is a master class in visual
effects and taps into a whole new
dimension several of them actually for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe to explore
but with so many elements in play from
time manipulation to the multiverse to
metaphysics and even magic flying cloaks
there was so much to explain that they
were bound to be a few loose ends left
straggling here are some of the major
questions Doctor Strange left unanswered
your mind looking at the world through a
keyhole fair warning this video is
filled with spoilers so those who
haven't seen the movie yet should hang
out another dimension for the time being
why earth as with many of Marvel's movie
properties our mega villain of the day
Dormammu is a creature that defies all
logic he or should we say it is a being
existing outside time and space that
likes to feed on the many generous parts
of the universe that give light and he's
set a giant purple eye on earth of all
planets why does our blue green blob
become such an important conquest for
Dormammu our best guess is it wouldn't
be a movie if not that's why how ancient
Doctor Strange asked the question we're
all wondering about exactly how ancient
is the ancient one we never find out
Mordo does spill some vague details
about how she's of celtic descent but
nobody knows anything more than that we
can only imagine how she became this
bald scarred sophisticated wizard and
certainly have no idea why she'd stick
around earth if she had a limited access
to the entire continuum of existence why
Mordo mortal came to the ancient one
with an injury of his own but we don't
know any details more importantly it
isn't clear why he was ever chosen to be
the Ancient Ones apparent
second-in-command
she certainly doesn't inspire confidence
when she tells strangers he thinks Mordo
has an inflexible soul and can only
conjure up he's strong as a compliment
for the character why did she pluck him
to be a right-hand man if she thought he
was so stiff Palmer who obviously Doctor
Strange and Kristine Palmer have a
history together but we aren't getting
the whole story here on the one hand
he's quick to lash out at her cruel
words that demean their past romance on
the other he clings to a watch she gave
him with an inscription about their love
standing the test of time and turns to
her multiple times for help so what
gives what's the magic rule those
sorcerer protégées were pretty loose
lived about kamar Taj weren't they
Pangborn new strange for all of two
minutes before he left the source of his
healing slip and more dough was quick to
guide in there
no questions asked when he heard and
muttered the name in passing it's all a
matter of moving the plot along in both
cases of course but are there any rules
to when how or why you can just divulge
this information to strangers seems like
they might be a little more guarded
about their precious sanctuary as all
were Santa
whose cloak we're told the cloak of
levitation is a fickle creature but
that's basically all we know about it
it's a compliment to strange that the
cloak has chosen him but why what became
of its last owner did the ancient one
know this person is it a sentient being
the other magical artifacts we saw
didn't seem to have such strong
personalities so what makes the cloak so
different no hands
when strange first joins the crew at
kamar Taj he's not strong enough to heal
his damaged hands but after he ascends
to untold strength and capability he's
still not able or perhaps not willing to
undo the nerve damage to his hands is it
because the one-handed master showed off
his fire-spinning skills and changed his
mind or is he just incapable of willing
his cells and nerves to correct
themselves hard to say no mask Casillas
and his cords all got some purple skin
masks complete with scaly stone man
wrought around their eyes once they
started channeling dark power however
they only shared one facial tell with
the ancient one who done the same the
insignia on their foreheads why is it
that she was immune to the Dormammu mask
but not the symbol when she was
channeling dark power why wait it
doesn't really make sense for the angel
went to die when she does remember her
big speech about how the body has the
ability to heal itself with the right
spiritual motivation no matter how grave
her wounds might have been during the
battle with Casillas she should have
been able to help herself
unless this was kind of an obi-wan
kenobe help Luke with the forest kind of
thing
[Music]
but then we've still got some other
questions dr. strange definitely had the
ability to manipulate time by the point
of her ultimate injury so why didn't he
whip out his event rehearsal trick to
save her or the London sanctum or undo
everything in New York for that matter
this doesn't make any sense not
everything has to okay no fair when dr.
strange vanishes castelia sin his
lackeys to Dormammu his dimension they
float up and are instantly flayed alive
or so it seems he says they're still
getting their wish for eternal life but
it isn't going to be pleasant what
strange experience during his limited
time in dormammu's dimension was an
endless barrage of brutality are we to
assume that's what's coming their way -
they're obviously in the doghouse after
picking the fight that led dr. strange
dormammu's breakfast nook but castelia
swooz clearly a powerful sorcerer
so Dormammu will probably keep him on
his team right why Pangborn in the
post-credits scene Mordo has broken bad
after learning that the ancient one had
been lying to him and drawing on dark
energy mortos new mission is to trim
down the list of magicians around the
world and his first victim of sorcery
stripping is Jonathan Pangborn this was
a guy who had nothing to do with any of
this stuff and expressly chose not to be
a part of the Ancient Ones army so why
him was mortal getting vengeance for
Pangborn sending strange to kamar Taj or
was the guy just doing more than
shooting hoops in his downtime thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and don't forget to check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]